Hales go impress - beautiful so this
game was suggested to me by a friend I
have no idea what to expect but
apparently my reaction to it might be
funny so that's all line now chapter one
life's begin 2002 senior year high
school but it says MSN is this tab it
did I get to pick my screen name my old
screen name was actually let's go okay
well I gets to like my buddy icon
settings this is a trip to the past
isn't it I I don't know what the skater
boy that's me alright
so for the LCU who are too young this is
how chatting used to look like back in
the day so Emily 35 sign-in we can say
hello alright hello there's our profile
we live in a beautiful world yeah we do
yeah we do cold place why fear death
just because you know the song will end
is that any reason not to listen
oh my god kill me please so what's up I
always go with nothing much nothing just
listening to some music
perhaps some complain uh okay so I'm
gonna have to say I like them because
I'm guessing that I want to have sex
with this em burly girl yes totally I
don't like to hold Coldplay I think
they're totally [ __ ] overrated
they're copying Radiohead and that's all
I'm gonna say about that are you going
to Travis party tonight okay this is our
moment
number three depends if you're going and
we didn't write the smiley face well and
so you should go what is the point of
this I don't understand like you know
Brad from our math class he won't stop
messaging me right now oh I hate when
girls used to do that like you're trying
to you're trying to talk to a girl and
then she's like empty and you'd be shut
up
you should just ignore him
man that MSN game was hard man I never
mastered it feel like this is my second
chance that's my plan he keeps saying he
wants to talk but maybe he'll get the
hint oh my god this is taking too much
if you have any more
oh god blink 182 Travis Tom an epic
party tonight bump ass party this
weekend whole class is invited me Casa
you can't stop the waves but you can
learn to surf okay I'm gonna go to
engineering school that's actually true
that's what I did and we we saw we know
how that turned out even though you were
going to be we go into different schools
do you promise you'll be there for me
I'll do my best
we don't want to be too [ __ ] waved am i
right oh my god you're my did I just
type you're my best friend I'm gonna say
this as it is right now if you don't
want to be friends with someone then at
least show them that you don't want to
be friends with them and that you want
to be more you can't just keep being
friends with them and expect something
magically to happen you gotta make a
[ __ ] move
okay she's supposed to come over head to
tries party movie well I see they're
definitely maybe she'll get drunk
something happens I don't know what this
chapter two
oh my god it goes on huh all right
stepping up my profile now in 2003 I
guess Felix hey how's it shaking oh god
what you listening to now snow blue
[ __ ] Snow Patrol they just came out
with a new album have you heard of it
yes it's great it's the point of this
game to break out of the friendzone cuz
I'm not doing a good job here
my favorite song of it is I don't
[ __ ] know the anthem I guess I really
like you what that's not a song of the
album oh god [ __ ] okay I have to go in a
few my friend is throwing a party you
choose to attend the House Bunny I'm
going to get so wasted you have played
all night no Brad has been practice so
I'm just hanging out in my door Brad
Brad a sneaky son of a [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] em smiley faces since when oh my
god Brad you son of a [ __ ]
do I know Brad oh god please don't say
yes Brad he's my
now whatever
oh no the party that's the thing well I
was away
Brad send me a ton of messages about how
he felt what did I say what did I
[ __ ] say Oh God
do you love him kind of question is that
Oh God yeah it's Brad ever meet Ian
oh he's nasty when they argue you just
serve better I wouldn't treat you like
that no no no no change
[ __ ] you you were so close
fruit sisters doomed to friendzone
forever you should break up with him
yeah let's go we planted the seed we
don't need to go any farther all right
we got this we got this we're gonna get
it out of here don't want to fruit see
my man don't want a fruit see okay what
are we into now the incredibles of
course all right Emily Hey this is so
frustrating how's life it's good I'm
doing so good without you got plans for
the weekend yeah of course I'm going to
a party
I'm very busy Oh my friend Emma I have
more friends apparently Jesus Christ I'm
so into this ha ha oh she's still dating
Brad that douchebag
oh my god no I had no idea how are you
what did I do wrong maybe you're a
[ __ ] stuck-up little [ __ ] Emily
you're an amazing person
oh wait what what happened fruits eat
fruits say my man
that's we're in we're in alright if you
[ __ ] that up then I don't know what to
tell you mate alright what are we into
now soon said it was pretty good
why is it Emily xxx [ __ ] what does this
mean what's going on I just feel like
things are weird between us
have you feel weird
I feel weird too I think of because of
all God what happened last year oh [ __ ]
what I thought I'd be good at this game
oh god here yeah where it is this is the
game over want to be in touch
are we still friends will we ever be the
same they're all stuck oh my god how
long does this game go on [ __ ] me five
years mate maybe it's not gonna happen
mate god damn this must be the final yet
please so weird to let relive that era
well she told me that she's always felt
weird about you visiting oh that's good
oh god do you miss me
this is going forever come on there it
is game over game over
Emily thirty five my [ __ ] yes 84 yes
84 [ __ ] it was it my Mean Girls icon
what did I do wrong